you've got 8 10 12 15 hours in a day to
get done and most people are wasting
time and this is your precious asset not
the hourglass not the sand but time
bruce lee said if you value your life
you will value your time because time is
what makes up your life so let's talk
about
the the concept of how to achieve more
in one day than you do in a week
here is something to consider we all
have
uh from the time we wake up to the time
we go to bed time a block of time and
it's comprised obviously of uh our days
comprised of 86
400 seconds in a day now here's what i
want you to think about if somebody gave
you 86
400
okay for every 24-hour period of time uh
number one would you be happy would you
like yeah i just won the lottery six
thousand four hundred dollars to start
off every day wouldn't you
invest that money wisely and what if
they also said to you that if you don't
spend the eighty six thousand four
hundred dollars you lose it it's gone
forever
how many of you would spend those eighty
six thousand four hundred dollars
all the way to the end and maximize it
if you would spend it just hit the like
or the love button because i would spend
it as phenomenally as i could and so
here's the thing to remember
everybody has the same amount
of seconds everybody has eighty six
thousand 400 seconds and so you don't
have less or more time than anybody else
and that takes me to the first point
that i want to share with you and that
was there's no such thing as time
management you cannot manage time
the only thing that you can learn
how to do better
is manage what you do
in time
now if you analyze or do any research on
highly productive people
they are two three four five times more
productive in what they do than other
people everybody and i mean everybody is
freaking busy busy with friends busy
with family busy with kids busy with a
job busy with their career busy doing
some of it's productive some of it is
not
write this down okay somebody type this
out
don't confuse
activity
with productivity write it down for me
somebody you know write it down don't
confuse
activity with productivity okay
so
what does that mean it means that most
people are doing busy work
and they're confusing thank you serena
they're confusing being busy and being
tired at the end of the day
with getting the most important things
done so that's why i said there is no
such thing as time management the only
thing you can manage is what you do in
the block of time
while you're awake
when you create
an action item or a list of what you
need to do
and you have a deadline to achieve it
your brain actually goes into a hyper
focused mode when you create
self-imposed deadlines and urgency
factors
so
when we teach our clients whether
they're employees or homemakers or
business owners or doctors or lawyers
makes no difference
one of the things that we teach them in
addition to having a goal
and in addition to having things that
need to get done
is to create a deadline there's
something called the pareto principle
that
that that says that if you focus
on the 20 of the things
that are the most important and you set
deadlines to achieve them
you will get your brain to focus on
getting those achieved so
in addition to something called the
pareto principle there's also something
called parkinson's law
when you combine the two pareto's
principle and parkinson's law
to say i'm going to make a list of
everything that i need to get done
but i'm going to
prioritize the things that are the most
important the most urgent and i'm going
to put those onto my calendar to get
them done first not last not after i've
done all my busy work not after i've you
know been on the phone i've returned 200
emails i've texted 16 friends i've
played on facebook for two hours no no
no no that's what average people who are
busy do
versus above average people who are
productive do
you have to change your mind shift the
way you're thinking
about your time and what you do want to
be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get the 10
habits of incredibly productive people
enjoy
habit number two assign meaning with
brendan burchard don't think of
productivity
as something that you're doing just in a
block of time
think of your life
as being a productively fulfilling life
that productivity is not a time
management thing
it's a purpose thing
i don't think of time management when i
think of productivity i think of purpose
i think of who do i want to be what do i
want to contribute
what will be fulfilling for me
because if you don't have something
bigger than just
blocks of time which are important
but there's not something that we
together are going towards
where it's this set of dreams
where there's personal meaning and there
is social contribution
we won't go
and you might write that down
you need both things as a mindset for
productivity
personal meaning
meaning you care about it you like it
it's intrinsically valuable to you
you feel like me doing this is important
because i like it i enjoy it it's
important that's personal meaning
the other aspect of productivity is
social contribution
i have to see what i'm doing is going to
matter to somebody
it's going to make a difference
and if we don't look at productivity
that way we'll just be like uh it feels
like a task but if we can assign some
meaning and social contribution to our
tasks everything can change
but ultimately
those things have to come together in
something to be productive for
like i'm always i'm like what am i
productive for
it took me a long time to figure that
out for myself based on what i do what
am i productive for
well at the personal meaning
i'm productive because i want that
vibrancy of being a creative
human being
i want to be productive because i want
to feel like i'm creating and expressing
myself that's the personal meaning for
me i also want to be a productive person
because the social contribution
i want to feel that energy and that
creativity but i also want to feel like
you know what my life mattered did i
live did i love did i matter how about
number three focus with bob proctor i
got on a plane one time a number of
years ago
and i was sitting
first aisle
right on the aisle
first row on the aisle there was a man
sitting behind me against the window so
we were sort of kitty cornered each
other
we were only on the plane a short period
of time he reached over and tapped me on
the shoulder
he said i think you could help me
is i'm a pro golfer
and he said
i love the secret
[Music]
anyway one thing led to another
he was on his way to the fedex
in
new york i believe it was
and after a day or so he missed the cut
but we had exchanged phone numbers and
he phoned me i said listen i'm in
toronto you're in new york jump on a
plane come on up here for a couple of
days
so he came up and we got talking and we
became friends and i went out on tour
with him one time one of the tournaments
he was on
and that night we were sitting around
the motel room
and
he said bob what's one thing i could do
that would make me a better golfer
i took my pen
and i went over and i put a little black
dot on the wall
i said i want you to focus on that black
dot bring all of your conscious
attention to bear on the black dot i
said the second your mind wanders don't
feel bad bring it back to the dot
and i said when you learn to focus on
that dot
for a minute two minutes
you will have developed a mental faculty
to a greater degree than probably anyone
in your family has ever done
it's the will the will is one of our
higher faculties we have perception
memory intuition reason and we have the
will
the will to the mind is not like hearing
where sight is to the body
all great golfers all the really great
golfers have highly devolved will
they have developed the ability to focus
now you might not want to put a dot on
the wall light a candle and put it off
at your opposite your favorite chair and
then just focus on the flame
every time your mind wanders from the
flame don't feel bad bring it right back
and focus on the flame
when you learn to focus on one thing you
can focus on anything because what
you're doing is developing a mental
faculty now the average individual can
only focus on a thing for one or two or
three seconds
and then they're distracted there's a
noise a light something flashes somebody
says something and like that their mind
is taken off track
people that are great at whatever they
do
have learned how to focus on what
they're doing all great sales people are
focused do you want to improve what
you're doing learn how to focus on one
thing
to the exclusion of all outside
distraction then this power that comes
into our consciousness we send it back
out into the universe like a laser
focused on one thing it'll manifest in
your life
it's the way the mind works how about
number four do creative work first with
marie forleo a big mistake that's really
easy to make in today's world is to try
and do all the little things and knock
them out first and then you have this
fantasy that you're gonna have all this
time for the big important creative work
later in the afternoon but
have you ever noticed that this rarely
friggin works here's why trying to do
all the little things first is a really
terrible idea because when you wake up
you have this full tank of cognitive
fuel but what many of us forget is that
we only have a finite amount of this
super powerful cognitive fuel each and
every day and every single time that you
make a decision or you resist temptation
or exert any kind of self-control you
start to drain your cognitive fuel tank
i want you to think about it kind of
like this ugh should i answer this email
or keep it as unread oh god where should
i make a reservation for dinner tonight
damn it gotta reschedule that doctor's
appointment
oh yeah you know what i really need a
haircut too why is he texting me where's
that poo emoji wait
heart emoji or poo emoji
ugh heart emoji
so
you decide do you want to use that
limited cognitive fuel on something
really important and amazing or do you
want to blow your daily wad on a bunch
of dumb crap that doesn't really matter
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there happy number five get up early
with robin sharma the key thing super
producers do
the best of the best
they get up early
so
here's what i wanted to share with you i
wanted to literally deconstruct the 5
a.m club concept which is just you get
up at 5 00 you give yourself one hour in
the greatness guide i call it the holy
hour which you're not in the world
you're not checking your
notifications you're not anywhere near
technology you're not watching the news
you're not chit chatting you're not
daydreaming you are literally running a
one hour period of practice to set up
your mindset your heart set your health
set your soul set the four interior
empires that i teach at personal mastery
academy
so that by six o'clock
you feel fundamentally different now you
might be saying robin
what
5 am
well if you're feeling that any good
idea is going to disrupt you any new
idea will shake you up a little bit and
so if you're feeling i couldn't do that
if your mind is full of chatter on
excuses if you say you know robin i
can't win the battle of the bed i can't
put mind over mattress my father
couldn't get up early mum couldn't get
up early grandpa used to sleep in i just
don't have the genetics to allow me to
get up early
yes you do we know from the research of
university college london
that it takes 66 days to wire in
neurobiologically
a new habit 66 days
and as you know from my brain tattoo
that is very well known all change is
hard at first if it wasn't hard at first
to get up early it wouldn't be valuable
change and it's messy in the middle and
it's beautiful at the end
so if you want to get up early if you
want to have a gargantuan competitive
advantage if you want to have a massive
opportunity because most people
they might have great products they
might have a great mindset they might be
great entrepreneurs or great performers
they might be working at a great company
they might have a corporate culture that
is fantastic
but most people on the planet will never
get up at 5am and that's why it is a
gargantuan competitive advantage for you
the rest of the world is pretty much
sleeping those of us who love getting up
at five o'clock we know it's the
quietest time of the day
imagine this having one hour from five
to six
just for yourself
imagine one hour
where there's such a stillness in the
air
where you can actually breathe and think
and be
and the spartan warriors say it so well
and this if you're interested in this
concept
the book is that i've written is the 5
a.m club and one of the lines i use
comes from the spartan warrior credo and
the spartans those great warriors here's
what they used to say
the one who
sweats more in training bleeds less
in war
and so
five to six your holy hour is simply
it's a training practice it's a training
ground like the great warriors so that
when you go out in the world you bleed a
lot less you have a lot more focus a lot
more energy you're focused on your
priorities and your values versus
society's priorities and their values
and you know what i want to say to you
some days i get up at 4 45 to start my 5
a.m protocol
and i feel exhausted and i don't want to
do it
and i say
why have i been teaching this 5 a.m club
concept for so many years to the leaders
i work with and the people who come to
the titan summit you know and people
like richard branson have been on my
stage and steve wozniak the co-founder
of apple and shaquille o'neal was in the
room at the titan summit a number of
years ago and why do i teach this and
why do i teach the protocol
well here's the key
not only will it fundamentally change
the way your days play out but the way
you feel at six is very different from
the way you feel when you first wake up
so
give yourself 66 days please understand
that getting up early is a gargantuan
competitive advantage and it will be the
single best thing or certainly one of
the single best daily habits that you
could possibly install in your life if
you're seriously interested in legendary
leadership being a world builder and a
history maker habit number six unplug
and reset with tim ferriss how do i get
a four hour work week is that possible
the four-hour workweek is possible but
you need to completely unplug and reset
and
the reason that's necessary is because
there's an epidemic and i do mean
epidemic in this country
of information abuse and information
addiction
where people have come to believe that
checking email 200 times per day having
a blackberry to your head or in your
hand while you're at dinner or on the
subway or in your car or with your
friends is the path to becoming more
productive and more successful you mean
it isn't
uh it isn't because giving everyone
around you every person in the world
immediate access to you is inviting
interruption and inviting minutia to
completely invade your life
which is happening to everyone did it
happen to you
it did happen to me i had no intention
of writing this book but
from 2000 to 2004 i was working at
startups in silicon valley i started my
own i was ceo
and i worked from 7am to 9pm every day i
checked
outlook hitting send receive 100 to 200
times per day like a rat with a cocaine
pellet dispenser
slept under my cubicle sent emails on
thanksgiving to prospects it was a
depressing scene and it's a very
unfortunately common scene and i think
everyone is at a point of overwhelm
there is more information than we can
possibly organize time management is
dead
how do you turn that turn that around
the way you turn around is you have to
completely unplug and reset that means
you need to take a step back
forget about what people expect you to
do forget about what's popular and
really look at what works and what is
consuming your time
so there are four steps there's
definition
elimination
automation and liberation definition is
simple first need to define your ideal
lifestyle
what do you want to be doing from when
you wake up when you go to sleep
and so what do you want to have what do
you want to be what do you want to do
and how much does that ideal lifestyle
cost and that becomes your target
elimination is simple it's getting rid
of everything all the static all the
noise all the interruptions all the
micromanaging all the people possible
that interfere with getting you to that
ideal lifestyle
the third automation is about taking the
few remaining tasks
that are important but time consuming
and either delegating automating
or somehow outsourcing them so in my
particular case i have an army of mbas
in india about 25 of them who work for
four dollars an hour and take care of
tasks that would otherwise consume
hundreds of my hours
and then the last step liberation is
about the final ingredient in lifestyle
design which is mobility and then also
how to use the time once you create it
how about number seven develop clear
goals with brian tracy develop clear
goals and write them down
because higher productivity begins with
clear goals goal setting is a key
component of our coaching program as you
know a goal must be specific and
measurable to be effective in guarding
your behavior it must reflect your
beliefs and be within your power to
achieve write a clear action plan
if you want to turbocharge your
productivity make sure that you have a
clear written plan of action every
minute you spend in careful planning
will save you as many as 10 minutes in
execution habit number eight find an
effortless state with greg mcewen
there's just three concentric circles
it's a very inside out approach to the
challenge of being burned out the first
is state the second is action and the
third is results
the context is or the contrast is
you can
sometimes live life where you're
exhausted your state is exhausted it's a
state of suffering
uh you you're yes you're burned out
physically
but you're also sort of burned out
mentally uh you're full of negative
thinking and
criticism and self-criticism and so on
you you're holding grudges emotionally
you're angry
and that's like that's like a state a
lot of people start to live in as if
that's the only path and it clouds their
whole vision so what happens then is
your action tends to be exhausted action
it can often make things worse in your
attempt to make them better you over
complicate you over
over exert
uh
and what kind of results do you get you
tend to get these exhausted results you
don't get the optimal results and then
the cycle continues so that's sort of
the the the path we don't want the the
the effortless path is about finding an
effortless state which most people have
experienced but sometimes just
sort of
briefly you know where you are
physically rested where you're
emotionally at peace where you've let go
of those grudges where you're just not
carrying those burdens anymore you live
more in gratitude than in complaint
and because of that it tends to make
your action more effortless
you stop trying to uh overcompensate
uh you you you say well why i don't need
to be perfect i don't have to try and
prove anything all the time to everyone
i can take i can have the courage to be
rubbish and just learn as i go with this
i can have a more lightweight approach a
simpler
approach to getting things done
and then this also makes it easier to
get the results you're looking for to
flow to you
again and again so you're not just
chasing it and going after it and
sometimes making it even harder to get
the results you want because you're
trying so hard habit number nine have a
not to do list with dean graziosi binary
thinking is either ones or zeros so
let's just take it in yeses or no's
your time is so precious we don't have
extra we don't have it laying around so
don't abuse it so start thinking about
the things that you do in either a yes
or a no does this thing that you do on a
regular basis does it take you to does
it make you more money does it serve god
the universe does it take you towards a
bigger version better version of
yourself
if it doesn't
then it doesn't and maybe that should be
off the list of things to do so start
thinking in life things a little simpler
right binary thinking does this serve me
does this fuel me does this take me to
another level and if it doesn't
then maybe it should be on the on the
not to do list like you know i talk
about a lot so binary thinking simplify
it inhabit number 10 the last home
before some very special bonus clips is
have a routine with jay shetty i believe
everyone needs to make time in their day
and even if in the beginning it's just
five minutes of each of this it's 20
minutes so the t is for thankfulness i
believe that your first thought of the
day should be a thankful thought
and the way to make your first day of
thought of the day a thankful thought
and i know vision in your meditations
you also encourage gratitude deeply
studies show that when you're present in
gratitude you can't be anywhere else so
you can't be in a grateful state of mind
and an envious state of mind you can't
be in a grateful state of mind and an
angry or an anxiety state of mind so a
lot of us wake up with anxiety
but what if you transform that to wake
up with thankfulness
and if you woke up with gratitude in
your first thought now you may say well
jay how do i do that
write it down before you go to bed what
is your thankful thought that you want
to wake up with often i'll go to sleep
and your evening routine is as powerful
as your morning routine at night i will
say to myself and write down sometimes
three times
i am waking up happy
energized and healthy
what i'm doing is i'm programming my
mind the night before i stands for
inspiration you have to feed your mind
with inspiration daily it could be
exactly what we're doing right now it
could be a podcast it could be a
paragraph of a book what i like doing
sometimes is writing down my favorite
quote and i stick it on a post-it next
to my bed and i wake up and i read that
first thing in the morning that way my
mind is automatically in the positive
eighty percent of our studies show look
at our phone first thing in the morning
before we look at our kids or our
partners when you wake up to news
notifications negativity and noise
you're now at a minus five in the
morning
you start your day with thankfulness
with inspiration
and i'm gonna tell you a few more you
end up your day with a plus five now
even if the day was tough you end up at
a plus two
and that's what it is you're putting
your shield on in the morning
m is meditation you all know a lot about
meditation at the base of it for me
meditation is just checking in with
yourself it's just being present with
yourself how often throughout the day
are you doing that and the ears exercise
this was one that i only added
properly if i'm completely honest in the
last two three years and exercise has
transformed my life i'm not doing it to
look a certain way i'm not doing it to
have a certain type of body i'm doing it
because i want to feel good and i want
to live longer and i don't want wanna i
don't wanna die because of my own fault
right like that's basically it like i'm
okay i'm okay with dying but i don't
wanna die because i didn't take care of
myself and so i just wanna put myself in
the best possible state so thankfulness
inspiration meditation and exercise five
minutes a day will change your life and
the more you do the better
if you consistently lay down the tracks
in teleco they explain that if someone
is really good at something they've been
at their edge over and over again but
what they're building is myelin myelin
is the white stuff in the brain and
myelin is like the connection on a you
know dial-up or do you have you know uh
you know what's what i'm looking for uh
glass right glass is instantaneous dial
up remember the old experience dialogue
well the more you do something with
enough intensity and with enough focus
on doing it as well as you possibly can
the more violent you build so when you
see somebody's a great dance or a great
singer and they can do it easily or they
say tell me how do you get up and do 50
hours with no notes or a six day seminar
there's no notes and you keep people
riveting well this is not my first rodeo
right yeah i've done this a million
times i always tell people you get
rewarded in public for what you practice
in private you look at somebody who's so
talented
they weren't just born with a talent
they might have you know a great body or
strength or fast twitch muscles but they
maximize that and that was done by this
practice that nobody else sees and so i
want my invitation to people say what
practice i'd say
every day stand guard at the door of
your mind my original teacher jim rohn
taught me that and what that meant was
feed your mind because if you don't feed
your mind
weeds are automatic so 30 minutes a day
of reading or listening because when
you're driving in your car i believe in
net time no extra time you're working
out you're cleaning the house you're
driving your car why wouldn't you feed
your mind during that time so that
you're stronger than you've ever been
before physically doing something each
day even if it's 10 minutes they get
your heart moving get your body moving
that puts you in that state that i
always tell people fear is physical you
can feel your throat your gut sows
courage right so if i go and i pound
weights really hard or i do a quick
intense sprint where i go in that cold
water there is a flush of your entire
body when you get out of your body your
mind gets stronger as well they are so
tied together remind the body where do
you find that
that shift of like i need to get off of
this because we'll be i'll be spending
time with like my fiance or with my
family
it pops into my head oh my gosh i need
to text this person i forgot i needed to
call and get this order fixed
how do you
find
that shift just say you know i'm
spending time with my family and i'll do
it tomorrow but not like in a
procrastinating it's an excellent
question i think if you're present
to
whether or not you're kind of in the
zone of time where it's cool to be fluid
you're kind of with the family you're
also sort of present on your phone
that's cool if you've decided that
because my kids are starting to complain
or my
is starting to complain that i'm always
like this then
you got honor that if you're going to
say i'm putting down the phone between
seven and nine o'clock tonight and i'm
actually just going to be present with
you you've got to honor it so what i
will do is i'll just jot a note to
myself you've had the experience right
where you gotta like be in a meeting at
the school or you have to catch a plane
or you've got a doctor's appointment and
have you ever noticed that when you've
got an anchor like that your whole day
condenses and you're more productive
because you've got this deadline and
that's called parkinson's law so
parkinson's law it's a research-backed
fact that when
you have work to do it will expand to
the amount of time that you have to do
it so if you have 20 minutes to make a
call how long will it take you
if you have two weeks to make it how
long will it take you
correct
so if you s every day
no phone in your room you set that one
priority that matters to you if you got
time to kind of inch it forward just a
little bit great you've already made
progress you're done for the day then
you look at your phone you also set a
quitting time right then and there the
majority of days you'll honor it and
that quitting time means for me it means
i'm not on my phone and everybody that
works for me if knows if there's an
emergency or if we have to do something
they'll call me so that that helps a lot
many of us have issues with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burned out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been so i hit a bottom
recently with this productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways i was
then blessed um i said a prayer i said i
need some help with my brain fog and i
need some help with my productivity
issue and i that day got an email from
the dr oz show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
dr dr mike dao and me and mike had been
in touch many years um for many years
just because he hadn't been an author we
were published by the same publishers
and mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day i'm like thank you
universe you're giving me exactly what i
need i go on dr oz with mike and i'm
backstage with him and i'm like listen
i'm feeling so
chaotic and i'm multitasking so much and
my i feel like i've got brain fog and
i'm i'm forgetting things and he looked
to me says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multitask the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day
to make a list of the five most
important things that i need to do that
day and not do number two until i've
completed number one and then once i
complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if i
don't get through all five in one day
i'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever i left off i'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
i did it i started to just be very clear
about the five things i was doing in a
day i told my team i made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and i made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
i'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
going to do five things i have been more
productive i have created more have been
more intuitive i have been more inspired
and i've been more creative i think
there's different
uh definitions of productivity i mean i
think there's if you talk to 10
entrepreneurs there's probably going to
be 10 different
um definitions right i think
productivity is a couple things one it's
a productive life that's focused on and
committed to producing and progressing
towards your
ideal vision and i also think it's the
use of your time energy intelligence and
resources in a manner calculated to move
you closer to meaningful goals and
productivity
isn't just results in getting things
done it's about creating free time for
your family doing what you want and
having 100 control
over your future i don't think it's
about doing more faster it's about doing
the right things
deliberately the first question i'd ask
is what are your biggest productivity
killers like what are the things that
have killed your productivity in the
past because if you don't become aware
we have to start with a ground level
here if you don't become aware of where
you're wasting time
that will always come up month after
month year after year so it can be
distractions as far as social media it
can be
internet sometimes it could be sleeping
in it could be people interrupting you
all the time right it can be
lack of planning maybe it's your
environment but i challenge people what
are three to five productivity killers
that have been hurting you in the last
let's say six months and i think when
you do that i think multitasking is one
i think notifications on the phone is
one but i challenge people what three
are costing you the most fridays can be
the most productive day of the week i
know it doesn't seem like they could be
the most productive day of the week but
they can be i know what often happens
friday afternoon if you're working a
monday through friday schedule you're
kind of sliding into the weekend at that
point maybe even hiding out so nobody
finds you it's really hard to start
anything new on friday afternoon but you
might be willing to think about what
future you should be doing and if you
spend a little bit of time on friday
afternoons planning the week ahead you
can turn what might be wasted time into
your most productive minutes of the week
so friday afternoon few minutes make
yourself a short three category priority
list for the next week career
relationships self making a three
category list reminds you that there
should be something in all three
categories so that right there is going
to nudge you to plan a more balanced
week and have a more balanced life
it doesn't have to be long just a few
short things in each but look at your
week see where they can go front load
the week if you can do as much of it as
you can monday and tuesday because you
know what stuff's going to come up could
be good stuff could be bad stuff people
ask my wife all the time what's
something about tony that nobody knows
and she says the level he prepares so
that was ray dalio i know i got a chance
to be with literally the da vinci of
investing most average people never
heard his name but right
you have to have a ten years ago jeff a
five billion dollar net worth and he had
to give him 100 million to start with
for him to talk to you right today he
won't talk to you and take your money
how much money you have he's he's closed
his fund out he won't he won't do a dime
more so to do that
i i couldn't i couldn't consciously walk
in and just say okay i've read
everything it's available i had to watch
every video there's only a few out there
i had to read every piece i had to like
tear it apart and see if i could
understand his entire structure of
investing so that when i was there i
could ask questions no one else was
asked before and as a result he actually
shared with me he's averaged a 23 return
for 21 straight years
billions and billions and billions of
dollars smartest man one of the smartest
man alive in that area and because i
understood so much we could pitch and
catch you know most people you know you
can just they just they can just throw
the ball right but i need i want to be
able to throw the ball and have you
throw it to me and throw it right back
to you right that's where we get
something that's really exciting and
because i prepared that level he was
saying to me after he goes you know this
better than anybody i know and he's so
it opened him up more and you talk to me
in more detail in the end when i go to
do an audience a big audience like i do
my date with sd seminar people do 20
pages of homework and i read all that
for a couple thousand people i won't
remember their faces i remember it's in
my brains when somebody stands up
something inside me recognizes the
pattern or recognizing this the pattern
that multiple people in the room need to
deal with and my brain clicks in and
makes it happen so i believe
you know garbage and garbage out as
simplistic as it is that if you keep
putting unbelievable quality amount in
when it's time for you to cash that
spiritual emotional
physical financial business check and
ain't gonna bounce because you've been
making deposits and you have plenty to
give you're not you're not just winging
it to see what happens so i'm intense
about that but i also love it because it
just i'm always growing too because i'm
always learning more than i need to
teach anybody else what's a tip that you
might have for somebody who's trying to
be more productive where do you even
start with that really
i think the biggest thing is to start
small
so one of the
one of my favorite lessons i learned
early on in college came from this book
called the motivation hacker by this guy
he's a
quantified self dude out in california
and he tried to do all these crazy
habits all at once and kind of
documented his journey and talked about
what he learned and he had this concept
in the book talked about called success
spirals where
you have to start very small when you're
wanting to build a habit and then you
kind of spiral up and you add more
difficulty you add more habits over time
because you're sort of leveling up and
then if you fall off you need to start
small again you can't start immediately
we were so what i see in most people who
start following me and asking me you
know how do i become more productive
they want to do all these things all at
once start getting up it's five in the
morning they want to start journaling i
want to start meditating start reading
you know a book a week all this kind of
stuff and you can't do it immediately so
the biggest thing for me is to find
something that speaks to you and start
with that and make sure you can get it
really solid so start with one yep and
then start small what do you mean by
start small uh it could be so say you
want to start doing pull-ups every day
start by doing one pull-up a day or
start by just making yourself go to the
gym and just getting there that's you
know that's the accomplishment for you
yeah and then start moving forward
because a lot of people
they see like a recommended program from
a pro online and they'll say okay i'm
going to do that every single day
because that's what i need to do when
you haven't spiraled up like nick says
you can't stick with that kind of a
program unless you're some sort of you
know ridiculous discipline robot
so you want to start smaller and then
eventually you can stick to that kind of
a big program
do you have an example of a habit that
you've done that you've spiraled up on
yeah uh so i mean i guess my whole
morning routine is a good example of you
know been able to add things to it over
time but
with pull-ups you know i bought a door
frame pull-up bar to one reduce the
friction and make sure i could do it
more often uh but two then start doing
more and more every single day and start
with you know like five a day and now i
probably do 20 or 30 a day
not at one set but oh i was going to say
like jeez man that's crazy no i think
i'm up to 15 in one set with chins and
then 12 in one set with pull-ups and how
long did it take you to get that
i don't know
i didn't really track it
so for that kind of a habit i just
thought all right the bar is in the door
so it's kind of like an if then
statement a program if i go into the
office i do five or six pull-ups i'll
tell you how i look at this in the
simplest form and
one of the frameworks should sound
familiar if you've read the 4 hour work
week 80 20 analysis i will look at and i
do this in fact instead of for instance
new year's resolutions i do a review of
my entire calendar previous year week by
week
for
in this case we just came into 2018 i'll
look at 2017 and i will make a list
in fact two lists of
the
the 20 of people and activities who
produced 80 of my peak positive
emotional states that's one list the
other side twenty percent of people or
activities that produced eighty percent
of my peak
negative emotional states
and it could be as simple as frustration
and what this will help you to put
together doesn't have to be at the end
of the year is a to-do list all right to
focus list and then a not to-do list all
right
and i tend to focus on these days at
least
taking
disagreeable tasks or distracting tasks
and first trying to automate them with
software auto pay whatever it might be
right a repeating schedule with a
taskrabbit for instance for physical
pickup or anything like that perhaps you
do that through a ups store that scans
and then emails your documents or earth
class mail
use technology whenever possible instead
of brute force with humans right even if
they're humans involved in conjunction
with technology so i'll try to automate
as much as possible first then if we're
looking at delegating which frequently
includes technology
again i'll try to remove the negative as
much as possible especially with
repeating tasks
that is the lowest hanging fruit then
i will look at my primary projects for a
given period of time
and if you have let's just say four or
five projects you could pursue or that
are in play in your life i will i will
narrow it down
by asking which of these projects
if moved ahead to the next milestone or
if completed will make all of the rest
either irrelevant
or make all the rest easier and i've
done this in fact recently in the last
week
then we have a primary focus this is the
lead domino that will make everything
else easier i will throw as much at that
as possible so let's just say
hypothetically we are trying to
design a website
in some cases
you want to throw money at a problem
doesn't have to initially be a lot of
money but throw money at a problem
instead of time time is non-renewable so
i will say go to 99 designs and get 50
different submissions to brainstorm
ideas for a potential website hire
perhaps two firms and have them all at
the same time
working on designs so that i can save
time and move this project
ahead as quickly as possible with as few
stops as possible if for instance i need
a legal opinion all right well i'm going
to look for a consensus i'm going to
look for
gaps to be filled by different people i
will very frequently have two or three
people work on that at the same time and
then gather their responses again just
to quickly review the not to do list
based on the 20 of activities and people
that tend to produce 80 of my negative
emotional states and then the to-do list
based on looking at your list of
projects and identifying
the project will that will make the
others either irrelevant
unnecessary to do or easier that is the
lead domino and then i throw as much as
possible at that
which does not
need to cost a lot of money and
certainly for me has not cost a lot of
money even when i was
i'm not gonna say in the poor house but
really really scraping by and very
little you can still find ways to do it
because there is talent both overseas
domestically and
there are many different types of
software that can help you to smooth out
and simplify process to make it much
more elegant if you're not doing block
time
here's what your day might look like you
have
all these different slots of time right
and you're just going to plug in as you
go through the day you're going to plug
in oh i'll work some there
and i'll work some there and then i'll
try to cram stuff up right at the end of
the day i'll try to cram that sucker in
any crammers crammers cameras cameras
okay just checking no judgment no
judgment you're just not going as fast
as you could
that's all crammers they're i love
crammers
just like because they're easy to get to
move faster because you do have that
diligence of when there's a deadline and
it's on you can go which really serves
you but we got to take you from a
crammer to a preparer to a high
performer and the way that we do that is
to look at this and go
listen if you keep leaving all these
time slots to randomness
what happens
is they start to get
filled
with the big d
distraction
some
reason it seems like this
hit home for some people
i don't know why
how many recognize what i'm talking
about here
so now
you add up
take this out
you might not be thinking too seriously
about it but let's say that's like a day
one two three four five six seven eight
work hours
you didn't know i drew that on purpose
now watch what happens if you leave your
time
to randomness you are stealing from your
greatness
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness bit by
a bit hour by eight hour day by day week
by week month by month quarter by
quarter year by year and decade by
decade and it's the little things like
this where you're like oh my gosh i
didn't get
anything done
because you've got all these random
approaches to your day your environment
is so important
and if you look at b performers or c
producers they really don't pay a lot of
attention to their environment
and so they get very distracted there's
lots of noises their phones are going
off maybe there's news in the background
maybe there's messy environments all
around them maybe there's toxic people
what i'm suggesting to you as the second
piece of technology to really 100 times
your productivity is this install
environments of tight bubbles of total
focus
the way i run my work life on certain
days i am very hard to reach and i
challenge you with great love and
respect be very hard to reach during key
times of your week
i mean i see a lot of people and it's
not judging them it's just observing
them
every time their phone rings they check
it or they have you know these loud
notifications so they're constantly
being distracted and we know what the
research says the research says we spend
2.1 hours a day
in distraction
we spent and it takes 21 minutes to
refocus your focus after you've been
distracted so if you are being
distracted by notifications checking
your phone checking your twitter feed
checking your facebook feed looking on
instagram checking all the different
platforms that is going to destroy your
focus
so the second piece of technology is
create these tight bubbles of total
focus and the way i do it is i have
certain days that i label as creative
days
and on those creative days i actually go
device free
and on those days i'm very hard to find
and on those days i'm in total solitude
and on those days i go to certain places
i call them my menlo labs just like
edison had his menlo lab and these
places are very minimalist and there's
no one there and that's where i do my
best work so install these tight bubbles
of total focus and create these menlo
labs where you're sort of you're
completely distraction free
and then you will find your brain will
drop
from the beta state into the alpha state
where you will do your best work and get
your best ideas tell your kid
here's an impossible thing why don't you
go out and fail
you say here's something worth going
after here's a step you could take that
would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
call that within a time frame within
some time frame that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's a that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named vygotsky he was
a russian developmental psychologist and
a smart one it's where the idea of the
zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone
you're expanding your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay i need to set a
goal but i need to set a goal that
someone as stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it and then you go then
you've got it perfectly because it's not
so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well i could do well because that
happens to people happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well i
set a goal and i didn't attain it so i'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you wanted to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
and being a victim yeah which isn't
helpful you're still going to be a
victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so you know because life is
this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem productivity is
very simple it's a measurement to me i
actually am productive 64 hours a day
and the reason that i'm productive 64
hours a day i call it the power of 64 is
that i focus in on having twice as many
productive hours so if most people work
eight productive hours i work 16.
i then focus in on the efficiencies of
those hours to turn the 16 hours to
twice as efficient to 32 hours of
production and then i look at the
statistical success of what i'm doing to
double that to create 64 hours of
production
so when people ask me how do you speak
internationally have your own radio show
on cnbc
run a business have a family of four
kids happy marriage travel do all these
things well it's easy because i have 64
hours a day
that i'm doing things
and it may sound silly but i've actually
changed my life by creating and playing
with time let me give you some examples
of what to do i take everything
everything that i do by the minute hour
day month year
and i look at it and i create systems it
may sound a little ocd or lane or
retentive but it actually works so i
took for example i brushed my teeth lost
my teeth and take listerine every
morning
and i took that and i started realizing
that i would days off and forget what
tooth and it took me an average of six
minutes a day
but if i stayed focused in the morning
and that small little thing that i do
every day i can save four minutes
four minutes time seven day was 28
minutes a week
times four weeks in a month was two
hours a month times 12 months was 24
hours that i regained a productivity all
because i stay focused when i brush my
teeth lost my teeth and take a shot of
listerine
other things happen i realize that time
is compressed in the morning
so
i'm not sure if you can looking at me
realize it i've spent hours of wasted
time in the closet wondering what to
wear
i sit there in the morning no matter how
late i am like oh
that or i've lost a sock or i can't find
the right belt
and so i learned this little trick that
i had when i was five years old is i lay
out my clothes at night
but the challenge is when i analyze that
is i didn't want to take away from the
time with my children at night
so i incorporated that with in laying
out my clothes so i took my girls and i
let them lay out my clothes
so they learned colors and sizes
geography where things were bought
finance i did all kinds of type of
things and now my six-year-old son
because i travel a lot he actually gets
excited when i leave
because he gets to lay out my clothes
and my oldest daughter who's 17 walks by
and tells me oh daddy i miss laying out
your clothes with you
see how this universal energy
has created itself into efficient
effective statistically successful
things in my life that have nothing to
do with business
it's a matter of putting energy and
creating the habits in performance i
want to talk a little bit about goals on
the light of how do you lose 37 pounds
and write a book i'm just going to kind
of give you that as an example for 24
years of my adult life by choice i
weighed well over 200 pounds
i say by choice because you see i have
never accidentally eaten anything
i mean it's always been deliberate
and when i choose to eat too much today
i have chosen to weigh
too much tomorrow
you can choose to set goals
and realize your potential
or you can choose not to set them now if
you choose not to set them you got to
understand that the consequences are not
going to be good
down the road for 24 years i was going
to lose that weight as a matter of fact
in 24 years i lost several thousand
pounds of weight how many of you already
know exactly what i'm talking about but
it wasn't until i wrote it down put a
date on it
listed the obstacles i had to overcome
identified the people the groups
organizations i needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when i
did that that the goal became a reality
and i lost the weight for 10 or 15 years
i was gonna write a book you know
anybody who's going to do just a whole
lot of things folks i was going to write
a book but it wasn't until i got busy
writing the book and writing the plans
first before the book ever materialized
now if it sounds like i'm trying to sell
you on heaven goals how many of you are
getting close already how many of you
are becoming convinced right quick like
that you need to have those goals
there's no question about it the
immortal jcpenney many many years ago
said give me a stock clerk
with a goal
and i'll give you a man who will make
history but give me a man
without a goal
and i'll give you
a stock clerk
now the interesting thing is golds do
not care who has them let me give you a
classic example of the way they work in
1950 a war-torn devastated japan
a nation which had lost an incredibly
high percentage of its young men their
cities were in ruins they had been
bombed out but in 1950 they got together
they meaning industry and government got
together and set a goal the goal was
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world during the 1950s in the
production of textiles
in
1959 ladies and gentlemen they
accomplished that objective in 1960 they
set another goal we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of steel now when you
understand there's no iron ore in japan
of any significance there's no coal of
any significance there we're going to be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel it seemed like
an absurd goal and yet they reached
their objectives they had taken all of
the steps in 1970 the japanese set
another goal they said during the 70s we
would be the number one nation in the
world in the production of automobiles
they missed it folks
one year it took them until 1980. in
1980 they set another goal and this time
their goal was we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goals you got
to write them down you got to put a date
on it you got to identify those
obstacles you've got to identify the
people the groups you need to work with
you got to find out what it is you need
to know you got to develop a plan of
action and you got to write it down
what's in it for me
now that's a formula that i have just
given you pure and simple do you know
that every living soul gets exactly the
same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time
figure it out
you get all there is
a hobo sleeping under a bridge or on a
park bench
that has no material possessions
none does nothing of any
constructive nature
that person gets exactly the same amount
of time as the most
productive industrialist in the world
we all get exactly the same amount of
time so it's what we do with the time
that makes a difference
i want you to think of the number of
time management programs almost everyone
under the sun has time management
programs
in fact i made one one time spent a lot
of money on it
and then i found out it was a dumb waste
of time and money
do you know why
time can't be managed i was having
breakfast with earl nightingale one
morning
um it was downtown chicago
and i was going with him on his speaking
engagement
and it was early in the morning he said
you want to meet for breakfast
el nino said you want to meet me i was
there and i always had some
well-prepared questions and i remember
asking him i said uh how did you learn
how to master time management you know
we're having breakfast i can still hear
his fork hit the plate he's what the
hell you're talking about
he's i've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
he's i merely manage activity
and he took a little card out of his
pocket
and he said every night before i go to
bed i write down six most important
things i have to do tomorrow these are
goal achieving activities and when i
wake up that's what i start working on
and if i don't get them all done i'll
add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six now if i have
three that i didn't get done today that
doesn't mean i have nine for tomorrow
like six plus these three
those three become part of the six you
have to do the next day
when you wake up you give all your
conscious attention to do those things
see you cannot manage time
but you can manage activity
you can manage your activities
make certain that what you're doing
really makes a difference make certain
that you're spending your time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
why do i focus on gratitude first thing
in the morning well i have my vision
board and then my goals everything that
i want but i also have a gratitude board
the things that i'm most grateful for in
my life and if you want to feel instant
gratitude just count all the things in
your life that you have that money can't
buy gratitude is also good for your
brain there's a cover story on the cover
of time magazine on these super nuns who
are living 80 90
and above and they want to find how
what's their longevity coming from half
of it had to do with their gratitude
emotional faith the other half had to do
with there were lifelong learners so
those two things combined are very very
powerful
after that i'm drinking my tea i'm
writing in my journal because a lot of
geniuses write in journals right
leonardo da vinci einstein marie curie
all these journals and they want to do
these studies they are geniuses writing
journals because they're geniuses or is
it the opposite it's because they're
writing in journals that they become
these incredible geniuses of their field
here's how most people though
unfortunately start their day they wake
up from bed and they reach over they
grab their phone and they pull their
phone to their face and then they go
and they start scrolling through and
some people you can literally hear them
growing you know what i mean it's like
they just immediately start the day
their real morning routine is starting
their day in social media now let's talk
about why that is bad scientifically so
not my opinion not like i'm the guy
telling you stop doing instagram i'm
sharing with you some results from the
world's largest study that's ever been
done on high performers
high performers are basically the top 15
percent of the most successful group in
whatever their category is meaning it's
the most successful 15 percent of
business owners or the most successful
yoga instructors or the most successful
videographers the most successful
whatever we've studied over two million
data points from 190 countries around
the world to understand what do high
performers do what are their habits what
do they do what do they focus on what's
their mind like not just like how do
they show up but rather what are they
doing willfully and on purpose and one
thing they are not doing is starting
their day in social media almost none of
them but think about what that will is
it's like you wake up you grab the phone
uh you start scrolling through
psychologically what is that doing for
you
first social media is triggering in your
mind the comparison frame
you immediately start comparing oh look
at her abs oh look at his thing oh he's
got this look at their followers i don't
have that impact i wish i could be like
this i want to be like that you're
immediately comparing your life to other
people what else are you doing you're
scrolling and as you're scrolling
neurologically we know that as doing the
reason you like to scroll so much and
swipe so much and move so much through
that phone
is because every time you do it fires
off in your brain something called
novelty and when we have novelties
something new to look at our brain likes
it and our brain says well let's give
them a little dopamine a little vast
suppression let's make them feel good
and so oh the more i do this the more
your brain goes distraction yay look new
things shiny same thing and you're
swiping through this and as you are
swiping through all of this you are
forgetting your life and your day i mean
imagine would you ever tell like a
middle school kid hey what i want you to
do uh kid is wake up every morning and
immediately start thinking about how the
other kids in school are and start
comparing yourself to everybody
no none of us as adults would teach
small children to start their day
comparing themselves to other people
and yet that's what you're doing when
you pick up that phone
what you're doing is you are
neurologically training your brain
to be rewarded by comparison and
distraction because right think about
the anchor here wake up grab
look scroll and what is that doing it is
training your brain first thing in the
morning
check out of your life and check into
other people's lives
every morning you are training your
brain to check into other people's lives
not
carefully and strategically and
intentionally think about yours so what
that means is if your person
who is checking your phone first thing
in the morning going through social
media
you by definition
by checking into other people's lives
comparisons yourself to other people's
lives you are ultimately training your
brain neurologically
to live
other people's lives
to see life from the perspective of
other people's versus your own vision
your own dream your own thoughts your
own strategy your own intention
you are training your brain to live
other people's lives
so that's the worst thing you can do
please be thoughtful about this and i
know i know when you're like but it's
hard brendan i just love to pick up the
phone i know i know because that's an
addiction
every time you do something if you have
to do it every day and it's something
that you do every day that is leading to
a negative result that's an addiction
and you must teach yourself to break
that you must not do that i had to
personally i literally do not have my
phone by my bedside
like when i had this i noticed i was
like gosh i check in
i've seen the results i've seen the
studies why am i doing this so i turned
my phone off i put it in the kitchen
counter charging and i'm in the bedroom
sleeping which is really important right
to keep you sane so i think it's just a
change the worst morning routine we can
have is to immediately be in the day in
comparison and distraction
second terrible routine that people love
to do is they gotta check in again check
in
email i gotta check my email i gotta
check my email i gotta check my text i
gotta check this but listen your texts
and your email
are nothing but convenient organizing
systems
of other people's agendas
think about that for a minute what shows
up in your inbox or in your texts what
shows up in your messages
other people's will for you
other people telling you what to do what
to think what they need from you what
the deadline is stress stress stress
stress stress
and most people
are literally beginning their day
checking their text their voice message
and their inbox which is all other
people's agendas and needs from you
so again you are starting your day in
other people's lives and needs your mom
probably told you growing up as well as
to make your bed and there is a great
book
by william h
mcraven that says
it's about making your bed and he is a
navy admiral that talks about
if you want to live a great life
make your bed and this is a massive
number one new york time best-selling
book this speech went viral online and
it's something that is so simple
but sometimes we think about we've got
to have some complicated morning routine
that
you know biohacking everything we can in
order to optimize our day and really
when we go back to the basics
that's when you start to transform your
life everything goes back to basics
so make your bed first thing there is
there's something that happens and i
started doing this years ago there's
something that happens
when you
decide to take pride
in your personal space
when you decide to say okay i slept here
i slept here for
you know six seven eight hours
and i want to make sure i have a clean
space when i come home at night
by doing that you set yourself up for
success you accomplish something first
thing in the morning you build momentum
and you create pride and confidence in
yourself because you did something for
you you did it for yourself so when you
come home at night you can say wow the
time and energy i spent early in the day
paid off for me tonight now i can go to
sleep in a restful space so something to
consider try this for a week make your
bed every morning it's the last thing
you want to do because you want to get
up you want to go to the bathroom you
want to brush your teeth and you want to
get on with it but i'm telling you if
you take those two three minutes you
come back at night you'll be proud of
yourself
for what your past self did to help you
in the future i wake up at 6 15 to this
alarm clock that simulates the sunrise
then i pet my dog then i always make my
bed
this is a really important tip so the
night before you
are going to sleep lay out your exercise
clothes because when you see them in the
morning it acts like a trigger in your
mind to remind you of your promised
exercise and even though i get dressed i
don't feel like exercising here's
another pro tip
i
program my mind to be positive all day
and i practice gratitude while brushing
my teeth i brush with my non-dominant
hand which is the hand that you normally
don't write with so i brush my teeth
with my left hand because i'm a righty
and then as i am brushing my teeth with
my left hand i have to pay attention
because it's not really a natural thing
to do and as i'm paying attention i have
my gratitude practice where i think
about what i'm grateful for i love it
when the spring flowers are coming up
we've turned our family room into a gym
and uh i have
uh tagged a bunch of the classes and
instructors that i love for you to check
out oh gotta go to the bathroom oh
there's chris uh now let's get started
with the class braxton here we go oh
forgot my water bottle i have terrible
add it is true what do i put in my water
bottle baraka holly jacobs from sony
pictures television i love you for
introducing me to this
kind of hard to exercise when you have a
puppy
but makes you grateful
uh what do i eat for breakfast either a
smoothie or eggs from the chickens
across the street and i'm telling you
right now
your morning routine is everything so
get up early and find time for yourself
so there you have it that's my typical
morning routine and
it never fails every morning that i
stick to my routine i have a
much more powerful day and the mornings
that i don't stick to the routine
suck honestly because i wake up behind
the ball when i get up when the alarm
rings i have made and kept a promise to
myself
when i make the bed i am
uh completing something before i leave
the bedroom and i also
whenever i walk back into the bedroom i
see something that has been accomplished
i don't see a mess that needs to be
completed
by prioritizing my
physical and mental health
and getting some exercise in i not only
feel better mentally but i also release
chemicals in my brain that helps me
focus
there is no doubt that having a powerful
morning routine is part of every
successful person's programs it is
something that you deserve it is
something that you should create for
yourself and it is something that will
improve your life refresh your routine
why is this important i'll tell you why
that's this is important because there
is so much science that talks about the
power of your morning routine and
there's also so much noise out there
about the morning routine and i don't
know about you but when i read all these
articles about the power of a morning
routine i'm typically reading them by
some male influencer who clearly doesn't
have children yet or some male ceo no no
offense to the dudes but all of the
articles out there tend to be written by
guys that have
two and a half hours before work starts
to somehow drink mushroom tea and
meditate and go to yoga and exercise and
drink bulletproof coffee and sit in an
infrared sauna and i don't know what
planet these people live on but they
clearly don't have children or a job
they need to get to at eight o'clock in
the morning and not to make anyone wrong
i'm being realistic i'm being realistic
about the fact that you need a morning
routine but you need one that works for
you and for where you are in your life
in this season you see i had a morning
routine that used to take me 30 to 40
minutes
last year when i had more time i've had
a morning routine that took an hour when
i had time and the ability to go for a
jog in the morning i'd incorporate that
in the morning routine do you realize
that my morning routine right now
has been responsible for helping me curb
my anxiety it's responsible for why i'm
so successful and i'm able to be
productive my morning routine 10 minutes
long that's it it's 10 minutes long
because that's what works for me in this
season of my life here's the thing about
morning routines i think morning routine
envy is a real thing
and i do believe that a lot of people
lie about their morning routines
i think lying about your morning routine
is a real thing i think pretending you
have the perfect morning routine
is a real thing
um
i'm
i'm about when i'm home i'm almost 80 in
my morning routine i get it done
because it's super simple right so i
mean i think i need a simple one yes
and when i'm traveling
i almost never get the whole thing done
i think the key to having a morning
routine and morning routines are
critical
because how you start your day
has a
massive
proven impact on how your day turns out
there's one piece of research that i
think is really profound and this comes
from sean anchor i talked about this
yesterday but i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
you um this too susie
if you consume three minutes just three
minutes of negative news
of negative television
of negative emails maybe stressful
emails from work or stressful texts from
friends
you have more than a 50 chance eight
hours later to say you had a bad day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind
it literally sets your mind up to be on
the lookout for things going wrong
and so the reason why a morning routine
is is actually so important is because
number one
it determines what your priority for the
day is
and we also know based on research that
your mood in the morning
it impacts your productivity all day
long you must come up with a morning
routine
that you do
every single morning or at least more
mornings than not
that puts you in control of yourself
and in control of your day
this is what i do
and i cannot explain the power that i
get
from starting my day off and being
bigger than my excuses and being in
control
first and foremost wake up on time when
that alarm goes off get your butt out of
bed five four three two one go why is
that important for persistence the
reason why is because the first decision
that you're making of the day
is to actually get up and get moving
that means you are
persistently
bigger than your excuses you are
persistently bigger than feeling lazy
and you are persistently beating the
feelings that typically stop you
the second thing that i want you to do
before you look at your email
before you answer your phone before you
start surfing vox and vice and buzzfeed
and you know team stream and checking
out the sales on zappos and looking at
your facebook news feed before you pick
up the damn phone
please please please
figure out your two priorities for the
day
these are the things that matter to you
whether it's saving money and and making
sure you're focused on that or showing
up at work and being a contributor or
whether it's changing how you treat your
spouse or your kids or the person that
you're with or heck getting to the gym
because you said you would whatever it
is that your two priorities are
put them in your head before you pick up
the phone why
the reason why
is because of persistence the reason why
is because i want you to have a good day
do you know what makes for a bad day
what makes for a bad day is
snoozing
starting your day off late starting your
day off tired starting your day off by
mainlining everybody else's news feed on
social media and looking at everybody
else's life and and saying to yourself
oh my god they're on vacation or gosh
they look so great or their friends are
so fancy or my gosh they've got so many
you start off your day looking at that
you're never gonna have a good day you
gotta start off your day by getting up
on time figuring out your priorities and
then getting to work on them do not pick
up your phone until you have done those
two things i think the single biggest
reason why people have bad days is
because they start them off by looking
around at everybody else and seeing what
they're doing instead of having the
focus and the discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in control and with your priorities
front and center so you want a bonus
round exercise every day that's right
get up on time figure out your
priorities and exercise you do those
three things you'll be kicking ass every
single day they work out
i work out
[Music]
what
this is a big one there is a ton of
science that proves that exercise really
optimizes your brain your mood and your
ability to focus hence optimizing your
ability to get things done now if you
haven't read this book you have to get
it right now it's the best book on the
subject it's called spark by dr john
rady and we'll put the links right below
this video so whenever i'm coaching
someone that has a hard time focusing
one of the first questions i ask them is
are you working out and 99.9 of the time
the answer is no so in my own personal
experience i always strive for 60
minutes but at minimum 30 minutes a day
of just sweating my buns off and i'll
challenge you to do the same thing
because i know when i get that done it
really helps my brain focus and i know
it'll help you too now one of my
favorite things that i do now
is that i have this little post-it note
that i keep next to my bedside table
and on it it says
what are you grateful for
and that message
starts my day with a different thought
studies have shown that when you're
present in gratitude you can't be
anywhere else
so when you're having a grateful thought
you can't have an anxious thought when
you're having a grateful thought you
can't have a negative thought and so
it's so powerful to start your day so
grab a post-it grab a sharpie and write
a question on it that you want to answer
first thing in the morning
now you'll be able to tell that i like
post-its because as i brush my teeth i
have this post-it and i got into the
habit of this when i leave this monk
where i put it in front of me
and on it it says i am awareness this is
one of my favorite affirmations to start
the day with i recommend this to clients
to people i'm working with because when
you start with that mindset
you disassociate and disconnect with the
thought of i am the body or i am my mind
and if you think about it we always say
my mind and my body and spiritual
teaching suggests that we are actually
awareness consciousness and so that
reminder at the beginning of the day
sets me up to now look at my life as an
observer to look at interactions as an
observer to approach relationships from
that slightly
distant view so that i can actually
approach them with the love compassion
the empathy that naturally comes from
the consciousness post-its are great
different colors are great go crazy and
use post-its anywhere in your home to
remind you of powerful mindset shifts
physiologically
one important aspect of you
is your heart
the pumping station
for your blood circulation which pumps
life
across the body this one thing doesn't
happen nothing happens
this starts from left side
so we told you you know in india they
have told you when you wake up you must
roll to your right side and get up have
they left side if you roll and get up
bad things will happen to you did they
tell you
bad things are not about that
when you're in a certain state of
relaxation
when the body is in a relaxation the
metabolic activity is low when you get
up there is a certain surge of activity
that's why they told you in india
all these things are built into your
life which you're throwing away the
whole signs of living has been built
into your life they told you in the
morning before you wake up you must rub
your hands together and see like this
huh
not see like this you must place it upon
your ass
you do this
you will see god
it's not about seeing god
if you rub these two things together all
the nerve endings there's a heavy
concentration of nerve endings in your
hands
if you do this the system comes awake
immediately
you're feeling asleep you're feeling
sleepy just do this and sing
everything comes awake
so morning before you move your body
you get it awake first
and then place it upon your eyes
instantly a whole range of
nerves
connected with your eyes and the other
aspect of your senses come awake
before you move your body
your body and your brain should be
active you shouldn't get up dumb that's
idea
understand
so you do that and then roll over to
your right and get up each one of you
watching this video
opened two very special gifts this
morning
guess what
your eyes
i often say
last night was the last night for some
and we are blessed with another chance
to live a better life
and we can make the most out of our day
and thus out of our life if we begin our
day in a proper state of mind
here are the five things to dwell upon
as soon as you you're up every single
day
number one
begin your day with gratitude
don't just charge your phones
watches tablets or laptops the first
thing in the morning
charge yourself up as well with
positivity that will last you all day
and the most powerful of all positive
emotions that'll make you feel empowered
is gratitude
because it forces you to shift your
attention to your blessings than to your
problems which are anyways going to be
an integral part of all of our lives
second
resolve to have a positive vision
nobody including ourselves
is perfect
everybody has a good and a not so good
side to them and the tendency of the
mind is to look at the not so good side
every morning
resolve that you'll try and look at the
positive side of people and neglect or
deal with
the dark side
because the more we focus on the
negative our mind becomes occupied with
others faults
ruining our work our day our peace our
joy and even our relationships
third
trust the broader plan
tell yourself that whatever is going to
happen today the apparent good
or the apparent bad
is exactly what i need at this point of
time in my life
nothing more
nothing less
have complete trust
that every incident that's going to
happen throughout the day
that which is beyond your control
is simply a small part of a much larger
picture that will unfold eventually only
for your good and your well-being
keep reminding yourself of this as
you're confronted with challenging
situations
through the day
number four
do the small things right
although folding your sheets or
comforters may seem small they lead to a
very big attitude like the us navy
admiral william mcraven said
making your bed in the morning will
reinforce the fact that little things in
life
matter
if you can't do the little things right
you will never be able to do the big
things right and by chance you have a
miserable day you'll come back home to a
bed which you made
and a maid bed
gives you encouragement that tomorrow
will be better
and number five
decide to help someone
don't they say
everyone you meet is fighting a battle
that you know nothing about
be kind be helpful
invest the energy of empathy love and
kindness and people around you and
you'll receive the same back when you
need it the most
also try to have a spiritual practice in
your morning routine a deeper connection
which will illuminate your inside
so you can brighten the outside
one thing that i
that's actually a pr like a really
practical thing that i did
that and that is i had
uh this is again this is just like a
real practical thing i had
two cots
right slept in a cot slept in one cot
slept in one cot the other caught was
all my gear
and it was just laid out gun body armor
you know everything was right there
and
when i
when i got dressed to go out
all that thing was empty
and so
never forgot anything
when i came back everything went right
back on the cop same spot same spot
everything squared away
so those that to me was and i figured
that out really quickly okay just gonna
i don't ever want to forget anything
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna put
everything that i need right here you
got to have daily targets
every day i walk in with a target i have
a planner and basically what the planner
does is the planner starts off two
sheets of paper
it's got it's got it looks like this
it's a notebook right
and this is this is the right side we
start on the right side this is gulls
at the top
and this is targets
okay first thing i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna write down these ridiculous
targets oh i'm gonna get a i'm gonna get
a helicopter okay i'm gonna get a brand
new helicopter eight passenger i got it
in my head i got it mocked up it's black
it's got a 10x underneath it dude it's
got choppers i'm not doing that this
year 10 billion dollars worth of real
estate all this ridiculous stuff goes
here 10 billion worth of real estate
daily targets you need a daily target
what has to happen today what what
that i can measure today
uh in order to stay focused on my goals
tomorrow next week and next month if i
can't pull today off
if i can't pull today off you know in in
uh when you're recovering from drug
addiction it's one day at a time
handle today
i used to go to a meeting three times a
day three times a day every day seven
o'clock in the morning one at noon one
at eight o'clock people say that's a lot
of that's a lot of meetings man 21
meetings in one week
but yeah you know what i don't wanna i
don't wanna fall off man i gotta stay
focused i'm weak the devil's got me what
i did overview really fast overview as
i took blocks of time
from 6am when i woke up
to
11 pm when i went to bed
i took blocks of time some 90 minute
blocks
some 30-minute blocks
some two-hour blocks no matter what i
needed to do
i added 15 to 30 minutes to it if i
thought i can get it done in an hour i
gave myself 90 minutes to do it so
you're not
going from one thing to the next and one
thing to the next thinking that a time
management system is really making you
stay chop chop it's not it's not
designed to make you stay chop chop in
an aggressive
intense stress producing way
it's designed to keep you on path for
the things that you say are important to
you
so the first thing i realized the first
myth that i changed was giving space
inside of my day given space inside of
my time
management so i add 15 to 30 minutes to
everything
for example
i wanted to check my email for
an hour no i'm sorry 45 minutes every
morning so i put in 90 minutes i just
doubled it and i was never in it for 90
minutes so after the email after i
checked the email i had a moment to go
um do i want to go downstairs and get
another thing orange juice do i want to
do something else and so
padding time supports you so i block the
my entire day from wake up to go to bed
i add 15 to 2 uh 30 minutes to each task
then i block it out to the most key
tasks so the first thing you want to do
is make a list of the things you do
almost every day
so that's
for me it was have breakfast and make
breakfast for jilani it was get ready
for the day these are my major tasks it
was take jelani to school get jelani
dress for school take jilani to school
it was check my email
it was
return phone calls it was make sales
calls
it was picturelania from school it was
do gelani's homework with him it was
cook dinner for jelani and i it was get
jelani ready for bed it was my prayer
time it was showering ready for bed
myself it was you notice you see this
was 2006 and i still remember all the
major pillars of my day i may have
forgotten a couple out there like in my
morning i do my gratitude time but i
knew my 12 my 15 major pillars of my day
and i took those major pillars and i
dropped them inside these 30 minute
blocks
hour blocks are two hour blocks from the
time i wake up to the time i go to bed
my 30 minute blocks were primarily free
time
so i dropped in
three or four spaces where it just said
breathe you would not believe what
happened now i didn't do the same thing
every day but most of the days i was up
to the same thing and i had some general
buckets called ceo time that gave me
time to do whatever i need to do for the
business and then there was a bucket
called
home time i could do anything for home
so i had open space time allocated to
either home or personal or
business now whenever that schedule got
disrupted
whenever i got back to the schedule i
just dropped in to the structure already
set
what did it do for me
it allowed me not to have to figure out
what to do next it allowed me focus i
didn't roam around so much figuring out
i didn't spend dollar time on penny
tasks
i checked my email twice a day at 9 00
a.m and at 3 p.m and that was enough i
did two hours of sales two days a week
what did that do that grew my business
at the time i was making 72 000 a year
in 2006 when i started the very next
year after doing two hours a day two
days a week of sales i was up to 185
000. that's so that's pretty good it's
well worth the time management
and so all of a sudden there's structure
but inside the structure there's some
fluidness there's space to breathe i
always say this when people have trouble
with tasks put them on the calendar
you know actually jamie does that for me
when jamie's got something for me to do
she just doesn't email me and say hey
you need to do this she puts it on the
calendar so i look at my calendar boom
there it is i gotta go do this whatever
this task is done
so put these things on your calendar and
that includes
scheduling time on your calendar so that
you can have time to
consolidate your lists and do a review
of your lists you know whether that
takes that probably take 15 minutes to
do and
i guess there's a bunch of apps you can
use and i'm sure people will make
recommendations but there's a ton of
to-do list apps including there's one
there's native ones on all the different
phones there needs to be an alarm clock
where performance is measured
performance improves secondarily the
more you can shrink the time frame where
you measure performance
the better chance you can have to alter
that performance and improve it so what
do most people do they measure their
performance the average people in the
world measure their performance at the
end of every year
new year's eve right they take an
account but here's my life
here's what i accomplished here's what i
didn't get done and once a year they
take a look at themselves they make an
adjustment and their performance
improves
they measure their performance they
measure the results and then they make
an adjustment so they adjust about once
a year
pretty good performers shrink the time
frame at the end of every month most
companies kind of do an inventory most
people do an inventory they look at
their books they look at the profit and
loss
they look at their schedule and they
make an adjustment after they measure
that performance at the end of the month
really good people kind of get together
on a sunday night
if they're pretty good performers once a
week they measure their performance they
make adjustments and they move on weekly
and then there's really top level
performers and they do at the end of
every day don't they the end of every
day they sit back they look at their
calendar they look at the results and
they measure the performance daily well
who do you think is going to do better
the person who measures it once a year
once a month once a week or once a day
we all know the better adjustments
they've shrunk the time frames down they
adjust they get better they improve
daily
and then there's the max out one percent
of one percent performers
and they have a clock that goes off
every hour
every hour in their head the alarm goes
off in my mind it's sort of weird but it
works i'm addicted to it now about every
hour the top of every hour at 11am it's
funny my mind just knows what did i do
to move closer to my goals what did i do
to move closer to my outcomes have i
achieved the things on my to-do list
today have i achieved my biggest and
baddest outcomes of the day and every
hour did i move closer did i move closer
what adjustments do i need to make what
do i need to celebrate what tweaks
what's been accomplished so far an
hourly alarm clock goes off in your head
if you can get to the point where you
just begin to practice it and maybe for
now
you program this thing to go off every
hour just to remind you what did you get
accomplished maybe when that hour goes
off you know what flash is on the screen
your outcomes and your goals hourly the
alarm goes off hourly the alarm goes off
it will begin to train you to begin to
measure the time frame of your
performance every hour now let me ask
you a question there's a group of people
that measure their performance their
race their marathon is once a year then
there's those that do it once a month
and make adjustments and measure where
they are and increase effort than those
that do it monthly weekly daily
hourly i can tell you that i run many
days and i measure for my performance
hourly it will transform your life
you'll become more productive in your
family in your personal relationships in
your faith in your business in your
fitness in your nutrition
in your money in every area if just
something goes off every by the way it's
a five second just reminder am i move
closer to my outcome if i move closer to
my to-do list today what adjustments do
i need to make you'll be reminded at
that time of someone you forgot to call
an email you didn't return a meeting you
haven't asked for yet but something
you're supposed to eat hydrate whatever
it is if you can begin to have that
alarm just go it's just five seconds
it's just every hour it's just five
seconds and i'll tell you it happens to
me constantly now and i know that one of
the reasons my life has improved is
because i've shrunk the time frames down
of where i measure my results right
where i can recalibrate where i course
correct where i make an adjustment where
i realize i'm behind or i've made a
mistake and i improve a performance and
so so far can you imagine if you started
just being a bigger hurry
and you had perception correct about how
close you really are to your goal the
difference in winning and losing is this
much it's like a veil and when you
remove that veil you see my gosh i'm so
much closer i promise you one of the
things that you suffer from isn't just
like a lack of vision and clarity i wish
you more clarity and more specificity in
your vision and i wish you more
proximity that you knew how much closer
you were to achievement than you think
you are in fact it's the fact that you
think you're so far away from achieving
these things that's causing them to
constantly stay that far away from you
because you're not running fast enough
towards them you're not measuring them
fast enough you're killing your goals
and your dreams by thinking they're so
far away it kills everything if you knew
how close you really were you'd run so
much faster so if you altered that if
you altered the first 30 minutes to an
hour of your day and you just stopped
letting yourself be a reactor but you
took control and became a dictator of
your time if you manipulated and bended
time like i have to where a day is six
hours let the rest of the world think a
day is 24 hours by the way someone just
made that crap up a long time ago an
hour of measurement 24 hours is a day
365 is a year someone just made that up
and everybody's bought into it well
guess what i've made mine up my days are
six hours long i've just manipulated and
changed time it's a figment of our
imagination is how time works and what
if an alarm could go off every hour in
that mind of yours in that heart of
yours just checking just a wake-up call
just to wake up just an alarm hey am i
closer to my goals am i closer to my
outcome what adjustments do i make what
course corrections what was achieved
what am i grateful for it's just a five
to ten second reminder and you're back
off to the races again if the earth
spins around once we call that a day
if the moon goes around us once we call
that a month
if we go around the sun once we call
that a year it's just stuff people made
up right and so time is a figment of our
imagination and if you'd use your
imagination
imagine what you could accomplish if you
shrunk the time frames down we spend
over 47 of our time when we're browsing
the internet or on our mobile phones
procrastinating and we check our phones
around 86 times per day put your hand up
if you check it more than that
so it's no surprise that we all face
distraction we all experience
distraction we're all plagued by
distraction but often we think that the
opposite of distraction is focus we
think that we need to become more
focused we think that if we're focused
we'll feel less distracted we feel that
if we're able to draw our energy in a
certain direction and force ourselves to
absorb in an activity then we won't be
as distracted but this is just not true
the opposite of distraction is actually
not focus the opposite of distraction is
wait for it attraction let me explain
what i mean when we're attracted to
something we're completely fixated we're
completely absorbed we're almost
addicted and obsessed to that visual
that song think of a time when you saw
someone that you found attractive i'm
guessing you couldn't take your eyes off
them think of a time when you heard a
song and you had it on repeat all
throughout the day no matter if there
was drilling outdoors there was a
building being demolished nothing could
distract you from the sound of that
voice and that beat i know you can hear
it in your head right now
what we really need to do is increase
our attraction when we are attracted to
something we're naturally focused we're
naturally able to be present we're
naturally able to bring our attention
and our energy to that task that project
that person when we're distracted and
don't have that attraction we're
naturally all over the place we end up
feeling lost confused and end up
procrastinating as you can see we are
procrastinating and distracting others
so now i know what you're thinking how
do you get attracted to things that
you're not attracted to we all have
things in life that we love to do and we
all have things in life that we have to
do i'm sure you have a long list of
things that you have to do and you're
thinking jay i'm not attracted to any of
those things whether it's doing your
accounts whether it's taking the trash
out maybe it's even your job
it is my job so i've got a tip for you a
little trick a little insight that will
make your mind understand and believe
that it's attracted to something let's
take the example of your job it's
something that you have to do it's
something that you may not be attracted
to when you ask yourself why do i go to
my job maybe the answer is it pays my
bills maybe the answer is it allows me
to take care of my family maybe you
studied for years and feel that your job
at least engages you for that whichever
one your answer is that starts providing
some value to why you do that activity
when you know that you recognize that
you are attracted to be there because it
serves a particular purpose you start
becoming attracted because whenever your
mind says to you i'm bored i'm
distracted i'm unfocused you say no i'm
here because it puts food on the table
i'm here because it pays my bills and
takes care of my family i'm here because
i studied and worked hard for this
you're able to increase your attraction
to even the things you're totally
unfocused on
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some productivity motivation with
jordan peterson check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i plan
each hour and i probably plan each
minute and yes it leads to way higher
productivity there's no excuse
whatsoever